Good morning, everyone.
This is Jack Van Horn from the BD2K Training
Coordinating center at the University of Southern
California, and I'd like to welcome you all
to our Big Data to Knowledge Guide to the
Fundamentals of Data Science.
Today, we have the pleasure of Ali Shojaie
from the University of Washington who's going
to be talking on unsupervised machine learning.
This follows on the heels from our talk last
week by Daniella Witten on supervised statistical
learning.
This one makes a nice compliment.
Dr. Shojaie is an associate professor of biostatistics
and an adjunct associate Professor of statistics
at the University of Washington in Seattle.
He originally trained in Industrial Systems
Engineering and obtained his PhD in statistics
from the University of Michigan while completing
a master's degree in applied mathematics and
human genetics.
His current research lies at the intersection
of machine learning for high dimensional data,
statistical network analysis and applications
in biology and the social sciences.
He teaches regular and short courses on statistical
machine learning and network analysis.
So we're very pleased to have Ali here to
talk about his topic of unsupervised machine
learning.
Ali, thank you so much.
Thank you, Jack, for that introduction.
And thanks also to Crystal for organizing
all these efforts.
I also wanted to thank Michelle Dunn, who
spearheaded many of the efforts on the BD2K
training activities and was key in the success
of BD2K training activities.
So as Jack mentioned, I'm going to talk about
unsupervised machine learning techniques today.
And this is one of the main two classes of
statistical learning along with supervised
machine learning, which was the topic of last
week's webinar.
In supervised machine learning, as some of
you saw last week, we use a data set, x, to
predict or detect associations with response,
y.
Whereas in unsupervised machine learning,
there is no response y.
So we're only looking at a dataset, x, and
we're trying to identify patterns or signal
in that dataset.
And that's the topic of today's webinar.
I should also mention that there are other
categories of statistical machine learning-semisupervised
learning, which is somewhere between supervised
and unsupervised, and reinforcement learning,
but we will not talk about those today.
So to better understand what unsupervised
machine learning tries to do, it's helpful
to look at supervised learning, which is more
familiar.
This is a classical supervised learning task
where we have observations in the space of
features, x1, x2.
So we have two features here.
These could be abundances of two proteins
or activities measured at two different brain
regions.
And each dot in this plot corresponds to one
subject, let's say.
So in addition to having the measurements
of different subjects with these two features,
we also have the labels associated with each
subject.
And so in this case, we have two labels, blue
and orange.
And so a classical supervised learning task
would be to classify the observations based
on the feature space.
So an example would be to define a support
vector classifier, which would be a hyperplane
that would distinguish the blue and orange
classes.
And then we could use this classifier that
we learned, let's say, based on some training
data in order to predict the outcome of future
observations.
The main difference from supervised learning
in the setting of unsupervised learning is
that we still have the same data, we still
have the same features x1 and x2, but we no
longer have the labels for the classes.
So instead of having the setting where we
have blue and orange points, we just have,
let's say, gray points.
We don't know what these points correspond
to.
All we know is that we have measurements of
x1 and x2.
So we can't, for example, do classification
anymore.
However, we could still think about whether
there are groupings in the data.
So this would correspond to a clustering task.
Or whether there are lower dimensional representations
that could capture information in the data.
Or whether there are associations between
the features, for example, in this case, x1
and x2, that would be meaningful and would
help us to identify some patterns in the data.
So to summarize, the main difference between
supervised learning and unsupervised learning
is that, in supervised learning, we have a
data matrix, x, which is an n by p array of
data corresponding to p measurements for each
of n subjects.
In the previous example, p was 2.
We had two measurements in general.
We could have more.
And in biological applications, especially
in biomedical big data, we usually have p
in the order of thousands or hundreds of thousands.
And y is a vector of outcome or response for
each one of the subjects.
In unsupervised learning, we still have the
same data matrix, x, but we no longer have
a vector of outcome or response.
And all we are doing is to look at the data
matrix in order to identify patterns or signal
that is interesting.
Now, why do we use unsupervised learning given
that there's no association with the outcome?
Well, unsupervised learning is an important
part of the data analysis pipeline.
In fact, unsupervised learning is used commonly
in the exploratory data analysis phase.
Along with data wrangling and data visualization,
a lot of times unsupervised learning techniques
are used to aid data wrangling and data visualization.
And sometimes, they are used to generate new
hypotheses that we could then validate in
independent data.
And this is when we basically identify interesting
patterns and signal in our data in order to
generate hypotheses.
Unsupervised learning methods are also used
in conjunction with supervised learning techniques
and confirmatory data analysis.
So Brian Caffo gave a really nice explanation
of exploratory versus confirmatory data analysis
a couple of weeks ago at one of these webinars.
And as he pointed out, oftentimes analyses
are somewhere in this spectrum of exploratory
data analysis to confirmatory data analyses.
There are analyses that are purely exploratory.
There are analyses that are purely confirmatory.
And there analyses that fall somewhere in
between the two.
And for many of the analysis that falls somewhere
between the two, unsupervised learning is
used extensively.
It is important to keep in mind that when
we use data to generate hypotheses, and then
later on test those hypotheses, if we are
using the same data, the findings of our study
are still exploratory.
We cannot make strong claims based on what
we find partly because these might not be
reproducible.
We drive the hypotheses based on the same
data, and we have, in essence, validated the
same hypotheses using the same data.
If we want to ensure the reproducibility of
results, we should instead use, for example,
a training test approach that was discussed
in last week's webinar or a validation-centered
approach.
For example, we should use crossvalidation.
And we should do that on the whole pipeline.
So all the steps from data wrangling, data
visualization, unsupervised learning, which
might generate some hypotheses, all the way
to supervised learning that would verify these
hypotheses or look for association with the
outcome-- they should be validated in independent
data or in held out dataset in order to make
sure that the results are reproducible.
And if this is not possible, then we should
interpret the results as an exploration of
the data.
We should not get potentially too excited
about what we are observing in our data.
So with that introduction, we'll focus on
two of the main classes of unsupervised learning
methods throughout today's webinar.
We will focus on clustering techniques and
dimension reduction.
We will not talk about assocation rule mining
and graphical modeling network analysis, which
although interesting, we won't have time to
cover them in this lecture.
Clustering, of course, is widely used in analysis
of biomedical big data.
Here's a very well-known example of one of
the pioneering applications of clustering
in analysis of gene expression data, where
[INAUDIBLE] and others used clustering techniques
to identify subtypes of breast cancer.
And they later validated these clusterings
and verified them-- these subtypes-- and they
used them to define effective therapies.
Now, in clustering, the main objective is
somewhat vague.
The objective of clustering is to group the
objects into meaningful clusters such that
objects within each cluster are more similar
to one another than objects in other clusters.
Now, the reason that this is somewhat vague
is that, depending on how we define meaningful
clusters or
meaningful subsets, we could have different
number of clusters and we could get different
clusterings in our data.
Here's a simple example.
Depending on how we define what a meaningful
cluster is, we might get different number
of clusters.
One might reasonably say that there are two
clusters in this dataset, separating them
into red and blue.
Another person could also reasonably look
at this dataset and say there are six different
clusters.
And this just depends on how we define clusters--
how we define similarity within groups and
difference outside of these groups.
Even someone might look at this data and say,
well, there are four clusters.
All of this is dependent on how we define
meaningful clusters.
So this is one of the complications of clustering.
Similarly, the way that we define similarity
among objects has consequences in terms of
what we mean by meaningful concepts.
So here, for example, we could consider two
clusters defined based on two curves in the
data or two manifolds in the data.
These would be the red and blue clusters.
Or someone might reasonably use a different
notion of similarity in the observations and
define different clusters.
So these are issues that are important and
need to be decided throughout different clustering
tasks.
And different choices would result in different
clustering outcomes.
In addition to deciding what we mean by meaningful
cluster, we should also decide what we want
to cluster.
We have a couple of different options.
We could cluster observations.
This is the most commonly used option.
And for example, in the paper that I showed
you, clustering was used in order to identify
subtypes of breast cancer.
The samples were clustered in order to identify
We could also cluster the features.
This is used extensively when we want to find
genes that have similar functions, for example,
in order to identify proxies to biological
pathways.
In fact, cluster both-- we could cluster observations
and features together.
And this is often referred to as bi-clustering.
Throughout this lecture, given the similarities
of these tasks, we will focus only on clustering
of observations.
But same techniques and same issues that we
will discuss here will also come up in clustering
of features or in biclusters.
Cause So today, we will talk about two classes
of clustering techniques, hierarchical methods
and partition based methods.
And we will cover an example of each one of
these briefly.
We will talk with hierarchical clustering
and we will talk about k-means clustering.
Hierarchical clustering is basically a way
to get a sequence of nested clusters that
are organized in a tree structure, which is
referred to as a dendrogram.
And there are two classes of hierarchical
clustering methods.
We could build these trees in a bottom up
fashion starting with n individual clusters
and then merging them until we get 1 cluster
that contains all the observations.
Or we could do it in a top down way.
We could start with one cluster and use it
in a measure of distance in order to
separate the clusters further down and get
n separate clusters.
And these, again, are similar somewhat.
We will focus on bottom up approaches here
in this lecture.
So to explain the main idea of hierarchical
clustering, consider this simple example with
nine observations plotted on the space of
two features, feature one and feature two.
Now, when we use hierarchical clustering,
we get a dendrogram, which is a tree on the
left that explains how merging should occur
between observations, how observations should
be clustered together.
And for example, we could easily see that
in this dendrogram, observations 5 and 7 are
merged together.
And then they're merged with observation 8,
and then merged with observation 2, and then
later 9.
And on the other hand, 6 and 1 are merged
together.
And they are merged with 4, merged with 3.
And then at the very end, the two groups are
merged together.
Now, how are these dendrograms formed?
Basically, we should use some notion of distance
or similarity in our dataset in order to form
these dendrograms.
So going back to our plot of data points,
we see that 5 and 7 are very similar to each
other-- very close to each other on this plot.
So those are the first two that have merged
to form a cluster.
6 and 1 are the next two closest points.
Then those are merged together and they form
a cluster.
The next cluster that is formed is by joining
8 to 5 and 7.
So that's another cluster.
And then the next cluster would be adding
4 to 6 and 1.
So you see that as we go up the tree, you're
forming-- on this vertical axis, we're forming-we're
merging clusters to form bigger and bigger
clusters.
And at the very top of the tree, always we'll
get one cluster that contains all the points.
What do we need to make a dendrogram?
Well, we need at least two pieces of information.
One, we need a similarity of distance between
observations.
As we discussed in the previous example, we
need to know how far the observations are
from each other.
Now, we don't need to necessarily have a plot
of observations, but we need to have some
notion of distance or similarity between observations.
But in addition to that, we also need a measure
of similarity or distance between clusters.
As I mentioned, as we go up the tree, in a
lot of cases, further up, we merge sets together.
And in those cases, we have to think about
similarities between sets or distances between
sets.
And this is what is known as a linkage function.
So this simple example with two clusters with
two and three observations in each explains
the notion of a linkage function.
There are three different choices that we
will discuss.
One is that in order to define a distance
between the two sets, we take the minimum
distance between the observations in the two
sets-- between the points of the two sets.
And that is known as a single linkage function.
The opposite is to take the maximum distance
between the observations of two sets.
And that would give us a complete linkage.
And then we also have the option of taking
the average of the distances between the points
in all the points in the two sets.
And that would give us the average linkage
function.
There are, of course, a few other sources
of linkage function, but we will not discuss
those in today's lecture.
So we mentioned that there are three different
choices of linkage function.
Which one of these should we use?
The answer is that there is no best linkage
function and that the choice of linkage function
that is appropriate depends on characteristics
of data that are unfortunately, a lot of times,
unknown to us.
So to give you a summary, single linkage function
works best when there aren't many outliers
or the data is not very noisy.
But it's capable of identifying clusters with
diverse shapes.
On the other hand, complete linkage and average
linkage to some degree are more robust to
presence of outlier and noise in the data,
but they require clusters that are roughly
comparable in size.
And they work better with spherical distributions.
So if we have clusters that have the irregular
shapes, we might not be able to distinguish
them well with complete linkage or average
linkage.
And here are some examples that would explain
hopefully some of these issues.
So if we have outliers as is the case in this
data set where we have observations that fall
somewhere between the two main clusters, then
single linkage clustering might have difficulty
separating the two clusters from each other.
And instead, they might identify one point
as one cluster and all the other observations
as another cluster, whereas complete linkage
and average linkage do a better job of separating
the two clusters from each other because they're
less prone to presence of outliers.
And of course, in reality, you wouldn't know
which one of the two clusterings is correct--
whether complete linkage is giving the right
answer or average linkage.
The main difference is these few points, or
in this case, this is simulated data, so I
do know which one is correct, and complete
linkage is doing the correct clustering.
But in general, we wouldn't know the difference
between.
As I mentioned, single linkage is better at
capturing clusters that have nonspherical
shapes.
Here's a good example of that.
At the single linkage, especially if we don't
have-- if we have some separation between
clusters, we could distinguish clusters that
are embedded and, in this case, nested-- these
embedded clusters within each other, whereas
complete linkage and average linkage won't
be able to separate these two clusters properly
and distinguish them from each other.
And the last example shows that the setting
when we have clusters that have very different
sizes.
In this case, complete linkage could break
down.
It's the most sensitive to having clusters
of roughly equal size.
In this case, as you see, it forces them--
two clusters that identify to have roughly
equal size whereas single linkage and average
linkage do a better job of separating these
two clusters from each other.
Now, all of these examples that I showed you
were in the simple setting that we had two
feature so we could plot the observations.
Of course, in the analysis of biomedical big
data, we often can't plot the observations.
And we have no sense of what the shape of
the true clusters are.
So finding the right choice of linkage function
and, in fact, even finding the right choice
of distance between or similarity between
observations is often challenging.
Now, going back to the dendrogram, as we discussed,
at the bottom of the dendrogram, we have a
leaf for each one of the observations.
And as we go up the tree, these leaves get
fused to form branches.
Now, I want to emphasize the interpretation
of the dendrogram here.
And there are a couple of important things
that I want to point out.
One is that the earlier the points are fused
together, the earlier the fusions occur, the
more similar the observations of the clusters
are to each other.
So the fusions at the bottom of the tree indicate
that these observations are very similar to
each other, whereas fusions that have happened
later on indicate that these observations
are not based on [INAUDIBLE].
So that's an important piece of information
that the dendrogram provides us.
One thing in that goes hand-in-hand with that
is that the vertical axis in dendrogram is
very informative.
The height of the first fusion between clusters
containing two different observations corresponds
to how different they are from each other.
So if you look at these two observations,
for example, they are fused at the very bottom
of the cluster.
So that indicates that the distance between
these two observations is very small, whereas
if you consider this leaf and another leaf
in this branch, for example here, their corresponding
clusters are merged much higher in the graph.
So the distance between those two clusters
is around 7.
So there is a significant difference between
points that are merged earlier in the dendrogram
than points that are merged higher in the
dendrogram.
And the vertical axis provides us that information.
On the other hand, the horizontal axis is
not informative at all in the dendrogram.
So we should not interpret the horizontal
axis in any informative way.
And the prime example of that are these two
leaves.
Hopefully, you guys see my cursor.
Consider this observation, this leaf, and
the one that is very adjacent to it in this
leaf.
And even though these are adjacent to each
other on the horizontal axis, they're in fact
the last two observations to get merged at
the very top of the tree.
So they can't be any more different from each
other in this example.
So the observation at the horizontal axis
and the layout of the leaves on the horizontal
axis is somewhat arbitrary, and you should
not
interpret that in an informative way.
Now, depending on where we cut this dendrogram
or where we cut this tree, we get different
number of clusters.
So for example, we could cut the tree somewhere
around here.
And then we will get two clusters, these red
and green clusters.
So anywhere from the very top to the distance
7, we get two clusters.
If we cut the dendrogram further towards the
bottom, we get more and more clusters.
So if we cut the dendrogram some where here,
we get three clusters.
And if we cut it further down, we get additional
number of clusters identified.
Now, one thing to keep in mind and is important
is that, as we discussed, fusions that occur
earlier in the dendrogram indicate more similar
clusterings.
So if we cut the dendrogram further down,
we are cutting into groups of observations
that are more similar with each other.
So ideally you want to look for gaps in where
the fusions occur.
So in this example, cutting it at 2 or 3 is
sensible.
3 is probably the best choice.
But cutting it to get 2 or 3 dendrograms is
sensible.
But cutting it to get more clusters is not
very reasonable because then we're cutting
into clusters that are somewhat homogeneous
inside them.
Now, let's look at how these dendrograms would
look like in a somewhat more realistic setting.
And this is the clustering of NCI60 data.
There are 64 cancer cell lines.
And in each one of them, about 6,800 genes
were measured.
And if you use complete linkage, average linkage,
and single linkage, dendrograms that we get
are somewhat very different than dendrograms
I showed you in that simpler example.
For one, the clusterings in all of these dendrograms
are less clear.
There is less separation between the leaves-between
the clusters.
And then all the leaves are somewhat combined
towards the top of the tree.
With complete linkage, we get a little bit
more separation towards the top.
But with average linkage and single linkage,
basically, we don't have good separation between
the clusters.
Another feature of these high dimensional
settings that we see in this example is the
behavior of single linkage clustering.
And this is often due to the noise that is
induced because of the high dimensionality.
In a lot of high dimensional examples, single
linkage is not capable of identifying meaningful
clusters, and what we see is that clusters
are formed by adding one observation at a
time.
So as you go higher on the tree, one observation
is added to the previous cluster, and that
cluster gets bigger.
That's the dominant pattern that we see.
And this is often referred to as chaining
behavior of single linkage clustering.
So in a lot of high dimensional applications,
single linkage, despite its appealing properties
to detect clusters with diverse shapes, is
not very effective in high dimensions.
We discussed briefly hierarchical clustering.
It's an easy to interpret method.
It gives a family of nested clusters.
It's computationally rather efficient.
And it also works in high dimensions with
the caveat that we just discussed.
The disadvantages of hierarchical clustering
is that it doesn't really correspond to a
formal optimization criteria.
It doesn't achieve anything in any formal
objective.
And the final solution is chosen by the data
scientists or the analysts.
And that could be somewhat arbitrary.
And as we discussed, different merging or
splitting criteria could give rise to different
solutions.
In contrast to hierarchical clustering and
hierarchical methods, k-means clustering,
which is an example of partition based methods,
tries to find the best partition of the observations
into a priori defined number of clusters.
So we first consider a sort of-- that we want
to partition our observation to k clusters.
And k is given.
And then k-means clustering tries to partition
the observations in the best possible way
into these number of clusters.
It has a simple and intuitive objective function.
And it's computationally really rather efficient.
It could be applied to data sets with a large
number of observations.
However, the main drawback is that there is
no hierarchy among clusters.
If you change k, for example, from 2 to 3--
that instead of wanting 2 clusters, now you
want 3 clusters, there's no guarantee that
we have a hierarchy among clusters.
So the clustering memberships might completely
change.
To explain the k-means clustering, I briefly
would like to discuss its algorithm partly
because the actual optimization function that
is associated with k-means clustering is not
tractable.
Finding the exact solution to that is not
On the other, hand, we could find very good
approximate solutions using a simple algorithm.
The idea is that we first randomly assign
each one of the observations to one of k clusters.
And then we iterate two steps until the clustering
memberships don't change anymore.
First we calculate cluster centroids.
This is the mean of the observations in each
one of the clusters.
And then we assign cluster memberships.
We assign each point to the centroid that
is closest to it.
So here's an illustration of that procedure.
This is a dataset.
Suppose that we want to cluster it into three
clusters.
First, we randomly split the observations
into one of three clusters, red, blue, and
green.
And then we just simply calculate the centroids,
the mean of the red, that mean of the blue,
and the mean of the green.
Of course, in this case, these means are not
that different from each other.
But nonetheless, we could now assign each
one of the observation to a centroid that
is closest to it.
So now, we get these three clusters in the
data.
And in fact, if we continue this process,
then you would
recalculate the centroids.
And then even after 10 iterations, we don't
get any changes.
So in this somewhat toy example, we get the
partitions very quickly just by one pass of
the k-means clustering algorithm.
And in many examples, this algorithm converges
very quickly, and we get the results of a
good partition of data into k clusters.
Now, as we discussed, k-means clustering does
not give us a hierarchy among clusters.
If we change k, the memberships will change.
k-means also works best when we have compact
spherical clusters with somewhat comparable
number of members.
So in that regard, k-means behavior, a lot
of times, is somewhat similar to complete
linkage clustering.
And one of the issues that might occur with
k-means clustering is that it may result in
small empty clusters.
And this could be potentially due to presence
of outliers.
A remedy for this is to remove those empty
clusters and refit the partition with the
algorithm.
In a lot of cases, that improves the solution.
But nonetheless, this could occur.
Now, here are some examples of settings where
k-meas could work well.
In this case, k-means does a good job of partitioning
the observation to 4 sets.
It's just a partition, whereas single linkage
clustering gives just one big cluster, and
then observations on the periphery that are
just being distinguished from those.
Similarly, k-means clustering would be able
to separate these two clusters from each other,
whereas single linkage clustering, because
of this somewhat overlap between the two clusters,
won't be able to separate them from each other.
And it identifies these artificial clusters.
On the other hand, k-means, as we discussed,
prefers spherical distributions.
So it has difficulty identifying these embedded
clusters, whereas single linkage does a good
job of that.
And also, again in this example, k-means can't
distinguish between these two clusters, whereas
single linkage can do a good job in that example.
Now, in k-means, we discussed that we need
to know the number of clusters, but that's
also somewhat true about hierarchical clustering.
We need to decide where to cut the dendrogram
and how many clusters to include.
In general, this is a difficult question.
Like many other unsupervised learning tasks,
we need a validation set approach.
And these approaches don't work directly in
unsupervised learning techniques, unlike supervised
learning where we could do cross-validation,
for example, in order to choose the tuning
parameter in k-means or hierarchical clustering
if it's not trivial and it is somewhat difficult.
There are some guidelines.
For example, as we discussed in hierarchical
clustering, we could examine the dendrogram,
see where the gaps are in the dendrogram,
and use those in order to identify the right
number of clusters.
There are also some guidelines for k-means
clustering.
We could vary the number of clusters.
We could vary k and then look at the value
of the objective function over different k's.
And then the guideline is that we should be
looking at the, quote unquote, "elbow" in
the plot, meaning that, usually the value
of the objective function drops down quickly
and then it flattens out.
And then the spot where we see that the flattening
of the curve of the objective function usually
corresponds to a right number of clusters
for the data.
But again, these are somewhat arbitrary, and
they're not very rigorous guidelines.
Now, probably the best possible way to find
the number of clusters is again to go back
to the fact that hierarchical clustering,
k-means clustering, general clustering, and
unsupervised learning are parts of the data
analysis pipeline.
So we could, in fact, consider varying the
value of k, or the number of clusters, and
see the effect of it on the downstream analyses.
Oftentimes, as we discussed, we use unsupervised
learning to further to try to identify some
patterns and then use supervised learning
techniques later on in order to validate these
or in order to do some downstream analysis.
And the best possible way to identify what
is the right number of clusters for that dataset
that you're analyzing is to use a validation
set approach or a training test approach in
conjunction with that supervised technique
to, at the end, determine what is the appropriate
number of clusters that you should consider.
There are some challenges and caveats with
clustering, as we discussed.
There is, of course, no one size fits all
solution for clustering, or even a good definition
of what clusterings should look like.
There's not a single best criterion for obtaining
a partition because, as we discussed, the
definition is, by design, somewhat vague.
In biomedical big data, clusters could have
arbitrary shapes and sizes, and we don't have
a way of identifying what are the shapes and
sizes of clusters or understanding what the
shapes and sizes of clusters.
So we won't be able to distinguish these from
each other.
And it is very hard to evaluate how well a
clustering algorithm performs, especially
when we are working with biomedical big data.
So these are the issues that come up when
we try to validate and invalidate clustering
results.
And we should keep in mind that, again, the
best way to do this would be just to view
clustering as part of the data analysis pipeline
and validate it at that perspective.
The final point I want to emphasize on is
that the preprocessing steps, the data wrangling
steps, including centering and scaling for
example, could affect the result of clustering.
So again, we should see cautioning as a step
in that whole process and think about the
consequences for example whether we center
or scale the observations or variables and
the effect that that would have on the clustering
algorithms.
So now moving on from clustering to dimension
reduction.
As we discussed, the goal of clustering is
to identify homogeneous subgroups in the data.
On the other hand, dimension reduction methods
try to find low dimensional representation
of the data that maintain important features
of the day.
Today, we will only talk about probably the
most widely used dimension reduction technique,
which is the Principal Components Analysis,
or PCA.
But there are many other choices out there.
We won't talk about mult-dimensional scaling,
independent components analysis, self-organizing
maps, and non-negative matrix factorization,
and many variants of these methods.
This is a growing and active area of research,
but we will just talk about the basic concepts
using PCA as an example.
Now, why do we use dimension reduction?
There are many reasons to do dimension reduction.
For example, in high dimensions, data visualization
becomes very difficult.
We can't really plot many two dimensional
scatter plots if we have large number of features,
p.
We would want to reduce the dimensionality
in order to aid visualization for example.
Often, there's high degree of redundancy in
the data.
there's correlational among features, so we
don't need to have all of the features in
order to understand the properties of the
data or characteristics of the data.
There are many features in any study that
may not be informative for that particular
study.
You could think of these as somewhat noise
features.
And it would be helpful to somewhat reduce
the effect of these features and come up with
dimension reductions that would correspond
to easier analyses.
And dimension reduction techniques can retain
important features of the data while reducing
these noise features and also redundancy in
our analysis, both to aid visualization and
also to help with supervised learning techniques,
as we will discuss later.
So the most well known dimension reduction
method, dimension in principal components
analysis, or PCA-- the idea is that we start
with data matrix, x, the same data matrix
we had at the beginning.
This is an n by p array of value for n subjects
and p features.
And the idea is that not all these features
are needed.
You might be able to reduce the dimension.
And the goal of PCA is to find a lower dimensional
presentation of the data that captures most
of the information in the data.
And PCA is widely used in biomedical big data.
For example, in population genetics in genome-wide
association studies, PCA is used to correct
for stratification.
It's used to study patterns of human migration.
And also, it's used to identify and correct
batch effects.
In last week's webinar, it was discussed that
batch effects would have severe consequences
on the performance of supervised learning
techniques.
And usually as a pre-processing step, we need
to identify these artificial effects, or batch
effects, or artificial nonbiological effects
that are results of data acquisition or processing
steps.
And it would be important to identify these
and try to correct for these so that we have
a data set that truly represents important
biological information.
And one of the main tools and techniques for
identifying and
correcting batch effects is based on PCA.
So to explain the main idea of PCA, again,
let's look at a simple example, with two features,
x1 and x2, and some observations in this scatterplot
of two features.
Now, the goal of PCA, as we discussed, is
whether we can find a lower dimensional representation.
So for example, whether we could find a good
one dimensional representation of the data
in this example.
Well, we have some choices.
We could use one of the two variables.
So we could use either x1 or x2 as our dimension
reduction.
Probably a better choice to use a linear combination
of the two.
So we could form a new variable, z1, that
is a linear combination of x1 and x2-- basically,
a way to average the two variables.
So this would correspond to, basically a new
direction, depending on the choices of w1
and w2, we would get different lines.
And then the question is, how, do we choose
these weights, w1 and w2.
And PCA's answer to this question is that
the direction that is most informative is
a direction that captures the majority of
the variance in the data.
In PCA, we look to find the direction that
captures most of the variance in the data
or most of the variation in the data.
So in this toy example, that corresponds to
the direction of maximum correlation between
x1 and x2.
Now what if we needed another direction?
Suppose that we wanted another direction,
z2, that was another linear combination of
x1 and x2.
Well, to find additional principal components--
and these directions are referred to as principal
components-- we choose the subsequent linear
combinations that are orthogonal or perpendicular
to the previous ones.
So once we found this direction-- again, it's
called a principal component, or PC-- once
we found this direction, we try to find future
directions that are orthogonal to the previous
ones.
So what that means is that we will choose
the vector v of weights that is orthogonal
to the previous vector w, but still explains
the majority of variables in the data.
Of course, in the two dimensional setting,
once we find the vector, v, that is orthogonal
to w, then we don't have any choice.
That defines the vector.
This is always the case for the last PC.
The last PC is defined directly by the fact
that it's perpendicular to all the previous
ones.
However, if p is larger than 2, then we have
many choices for the second PC.
And then we would choose among those the one
that explains the maximum variation in the
data and is orthogonal to the previous ones.
So in this example, again, this choice of
second PC is somewhat clear.
It's the one that is orthogonal to the first
one.
And then basically, when you look at this
plot, based on the two principal components,
PCA just defines a new coordinate system for
the observations that now you could think
of plotting the observation along this new
co
ordinate system instead of the original coordinates
system.
And that's, a lot of times, how we use PCA
in order to do data visualizations in high
dimensions.
If we had higher dimensions when we have p
larger than 2, PCA again defines a lower dimensional
representation.
And in fact, it defines a lower dimensional
representation that is the best approximation
to the data.
So we can define this two dimensional approximation
of the data where we project each one of the
observations into this plane.
And that would give us the PCA solution.
So the PCA solution with the first principle
component and the second principle component
captures the majority of variability that
could be captured by a two dimensional representation.
This is the best approximation to he data
that we can get.
So here is a classical example of a application
of PCA on a data set that was collected back
in 1973.
And these are crime statistics in arrests
per 100,000 residents for solved murder rate
along with the percentage of urban population
in the 50 United States.
As we can see from the two dimensional scatter
plots, there is some correlation between some
of these crime statistics.
Murder and assault, for example, are correlated
with each other.
There's some correlation between assault and
rape and assault and murder.
And urban population is less correlated with
these two.
But nonetheless, there is some correlation
in the data.
Now, if we apply PCA-- I won't go into detail
of how we get these.
If we apply PCA and then plot the observation
of the space of the first two PCs, we see
some interesting patterns just using two principal
components.
So instead of now having four variables, we've
reduced the dimensionality into two.
And that allows us to do visualization, for
example, and identification of interesting
patterns.
So in the space of the first two PCs for example,
we have the observations plotted.
And in this particular plot, which is referred
to as a biplot, we also have the variables
or features overlaid in this spot using these
arrows.
So this shows that basically the first principal
component is somewhat of an average of all
four variables.
As we saw, these variables were correlated
with each other.
So the first principle components in these
settings usually captures an overall average
of the variables.
So long as the first principle components
has been moved to the right, we have higher
levels of some combination of urban population,
rape, assault and murder in the states that
are on the right and a lower values of those
in the states that are in the far left.
Whereas the second principle component direction
tells us something interesting about the contrast
between assault and murder that have negative
values on this second principle component
versus urban population and rape that have
positive values in this second principle component.
So basically, states that are at the bottom
half of this second principle component are
those that have higher rates of arrest due
to assault and murder.
And states that are in the top half of the
plots were based on the second principal component
are those that have higher rates of arrest
based on rape and also have higher urban population
in those states.
So already, this plot gives us some really
interesting information about the data that
we could not just see based on the 2D scatterplots.
Just plotting everything in the space of the
first two PCs in addition to dimension reduction
gives us a way of identifying these interesting
features.
Now again, the question that comes up is that
how many principal components should be used.
As before, this is somewhat tricky question
to answer.
On the one hand, by increasing the number
of principal components, we would include
more and more variation of the data.
We explain more of the variation in the data.
On the other hand, if we use too many PCs,
we don't get the advantage and benefits of
dimension reduction.
Ideally, we want the smallest number of PCs
that capture the important information of
the data.
Unfortunately, this is not easy, as we discussed.
And again, the best way to achieve this, although
there are some guidelines and some ideas about
how we could choose the number of PCs is to
think about PCA as part of unsupervised learning
in the data analysis pipeline, and try to
identify the number of clusters that is best
based on that.
As one example, in last week's webinar, one
of the methods that was discussed was principal
component regression, which is basically applying
PCA to first obtain a lower dimensional representation
of the data, and then apply either regression
or classification on that space in order to
predict the outcome or find associations with
the features in that space.
And this is a very powerful tool, especially
for prediction.
It's not as great for finding association
because you are now in this lower dimensional
space that is the combination of the previous
variables.
But nonetheless, a really good way of identifying
how many principal components we should include
is to look at the outcome of that regression
or classification at the end, and then try
to use cross-validation, for example, in order
to identify how many principal components
should be used in order to get the best prediction
in the test data.
To summarize, I want to emphasize-- again,
I know that I've mentioned this a couple times
and I've repeated this over and over, but
this is really important.
And unsupervised learning is just one step
in the data analysis pipeline.
So we should see it as part of the data analysis
pipeline.
And the results of unsupervised learning should
be ideally validated in that pipeline.
We widely use unsupervised learning techniques
to preprocess data.
So it's used in exploratory data analysis
to aid data visualization, data wrangling.
For example, as we discussed, its used to
correct for batch effects.
And then, its also used for data visualization,
as we saw some examples of it.
It's used to extract features and discover
patterns in the data.
So all of this was part of exploratory data
analysis, and we use it to generate new hypotheses.
But it's also used in confirmatory data analysis
as we just discussed in the example of a principal
component regression.
These unsupervised learning techniques are
used to improve the performance of supervised
techniques or in conjunction with supervised
learning techniques in confirmatory data analysis.
The selection of tuning parameters and validation
of the results of unsupervised learning techniques
is often difficult.
This is partly because we don't have a response--
we don't have an outcome to use, for example,
in order to do cross-validation.
However, if we see it again as part of the
whole pipeline, we would be able to use the
outcome of the analysis.
If this is not feasible, if there is truly
no outcome, then what you would want to do
is to try to validate what we find in an independent
dataset.
So let's say we get some clusterings, and
we should repeat the clustering on an independent
data to see if clusterings that we get are
somewhat similar, or if we use that clustering
from the previous study, whether those correspond
to interesting patterns in the new dataset
as well.
And especially, when we are using unsupervised
learning techniques purely as exploratory
data analysis tools, we should be cautious
about interpreting the results of those analyses.
We should keep in mind that without external
validation, there is danger that we might
not be able to produce the findings of our
exploratory data analysis and what we are
getting could be potentially just features
that we have captured by looking at the data.
And they might not be generalizable to other
datasets and other studies.
And with that, I want to thank you for listening.
And I'm happy to answer any questions that
they might have.
Thank you, so much Ali.
That was a really great overview on unsupervised
machine learning.
I do want to encourage folks who are in our
audience, if you have any questions to use
the little question submission system to send
in a few questions.
And I'll try and get to as many as we can
before the top of the hour.
One question, for you, Ali, is you had made--
in your discussion on the creation of the
dendrograms in your clustering algorithm discussion,
you mentioned measures of distance.
Are there any caveats about the choice of
the measure of distance, whether it's a Euclidean
metric, whether it's like a city block metric,
or perhaps even an information criteria that
one needs to worry about at all?
Absolutely.
So there are many choices as you mentioned.
Some of them-- there are many choices of distance
or similarity.
And the main caveat is that there is no best
measure.
That different datasets and different depending
on what are the clusterings within the data,
different measures might work better in different
situations.
And unfortunately, that's another thing that
we won't know.
And the best way to do clustering is to often
try different metrics and try different similarity
or distance measures
and see which one of them validates better.
So again, I want to go back to this idea that
unsupervised learning is part of the pipeline.
Which one of them gives us results that are
more generalizable if we look at the test
set.
So ideally we should try a couple of different
choices of distance or similarity to see which
one of them gives us more generalizable results.
OK.
Great.
Well, one other question was in principal
components analysis.
Are there any recommended axis rotation techniques
which might be useful in helping to make your
results more interpretable?
Well, so principal component is, by design,
a way of rotating the axes.
So basically, going back to the slide I had
on principal components, basically what principal
components does is that it gives you a new
coordinate system.
Basically, it's a rotation of the original
data.
Now, in addition to rotation, in a higher
dimension, you're getting this rotation in
a reduced dimension.
So instead of having a three dimensional space,
you have a two dimensional space.
But principal components already tries to
find the optimal rotation
that captures the information in the data.
The feature of the principal component-- the
property of principal component is that the
two axes are orthogonal to each other.
So that helps open up the correlation basically
between observations.
So instead of having observations plotted
along the correlation, as we had x1 and x2,
now, if we look at this new coordinate system--
in this new coordinate system, the observations
can be opened up from each other more easily.
So I would say just looking at principal components
usually gives us the right rotation of the
data.
A lot of times the question is how many of
these PCs should be used or which one of the
PCs should we look at.
Should we look at PC1 1 and PC 2 or should
we look at PC 1 and PC 3 if you are doing
2D scatterplots.
So that's usually the more difficult question
to answer.
So you should inspect your data, I guess,
is inspects the results-
Yes.
--and that will tell you-
--which kind of brings me to one of the questions
from our audience is there seems to be a lot
of supervision in unsupervised machine learning.
How do you kind of strike a balance between
how much inputs or trial and error that a
user might input with letting the machine
do what it does?
So that's actually a really good question.
In general, I would say that unsupervised
learning is one of the areas
that supervision, if you will, or involvement
of the data scientists is somewhat critical.
Many of the unsupervised learning techniques
are harder to put into an automatic framework.
A lot of times, there is need for data scientists
to be engaged.
And this is a really good opportunity, for
example, for interaction from data scientists
with the data at see what are the interesting
features.
We don't want to do this to the extent that
we are basically finding artificial patterns
in the data.
And again, that goes back to finding patterns
that are generalizable at a test dataset or
in cross-validation.
But a lot of times, unsupervised learning
techniques do require some involvement by
the data scientist.
So how does that-- your interest is in building
a model of the data, are there different approaches
that you need to be considering between the
use of a supervised approach versus an unsupervised
learning approach?
Well, of course.
We use unsupervised techniques, a lot of times,
to gain insight into what are the characteristics
of the data, what are the features of the
data.
And those will help us determine what are
the right models-- what are the proper unsupervised
learning techniques.
So that's one way that these tools are used
together.
The other way, as I briefly discussed in the
case of principal component regression is
that sometimes unsupervised learning techniques
are used in order to aid supervised learning
techniques-- in order to improve the performance
of supervised learning techniques.
So the final model is basically using unsupervised
learning to first reduce the dimension.
And then we build a prediction model or, let's
say, a regression model.
So we could use these in conjunction, and
use them together in order to get a model
that is most appropriate.
But the answer, to some extent, depends on
what is the goal of our analysis.
So if the goal is purely prediction, we could
use principal component regression.
And PCA together with regression or prediction.
However, if the goal is to find association
between the original features and the outcome,
that technically doesn't work very well because
each one of the PCs is a linear combination
of all the original features.
So we can't use principal component regression
in order to identify which one of the features
is associated with the outcome.
So the answer to this question somewhat depends
on what is the goal of our analysis.
Do we want to do a good job of prediction
or do we want to find association between
the features and the outcome?
And once we answer that question, it will
determine what are the right choices of combinations
of supervised and unsupervised learning techniques.
Well, fantastic.
Well, we've run out of time.
And so we need to kind of sign off now.
But I want to thank Ali for his talk today.
It was a really fantastic overview of unsupervised
machine learning.
I want to thank those of you who signed in.
And thank you for your questions.
And we'll look forward to talking to you again
next week.
Once again, thank you,
Ali.
Enjoy your weekend, everybody.
Thank you.